ce tron ces dernières années de nombreux
français ont rejoint les rangs de l'état
islamique au levant acquis à la cause
salafistes portée par la volonté de
contribuer au djihad armé ils se sont
rendu tristement célèbre par leur part
leurs exactions commises contre les
populations locales pour imposer l'ordre
tyrannique de dèche
il voulait aussi mettre la france à
genoux certains d'entre eux utilisant
les réseaux sociaux ont largement
diffuser leur propagande visant à
encourager de jeunes français à les
rejoindre ou à commettre des attentats
sur notre sol par tous les moyens
aujourd'hui un certain nombre de ces
individus dangereux capturés en syrie
sont détenus par les forces kurdes
le désengagement américain du levant
pose la question du devenir de ces
prisonniers qui pourrait revenir en
france
dès lors comment le gouvernement tente
il protéger efficacement les français de
ces criminels de ses ennemis de la
république
et alors que la menace terroriste reste
très élevé dans notre pays si m pour
vous répondre la parole et à monsieur le
premier ministre monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur allizard vous
m'interrogez sur le sort des français
terroristes détenus au nord-est de la
syrie
je voudrais commencer par dire que votre
préoccupation celle qui sous-tend votre
question la préoccupation du premier
ministre que je suis des membres du
gouvernement de l'ensemble de la
représentation nationale
j'en suis certain c'est de faire en
sorte de garantir la sécurité des
français
c'est pour garantir la sécurité des
français que des gouvernements ont
décidé d'aller combattre des shs dans
cette région et de participer à une
coalition
c'est pour garantir la sécurité des
français qu'un certain nombre
d'opérations ont été conduites
face à des terroristes qui quelle que
soit la nationalité dont ils pouvaient
le cas échéant se revendiquait étaient
des ennemis et on est traité comme tel
il se trouve qu'un certain nombre
deux combattants français qui se sont
rendus sur place ont été parfois
rejoints par leurs conjoints ont parfois
eu des enfants il se trouve que certains
ont été tués dans des combats que
d'autres sont aujourd'hui en détention
par les forces kurdes dans le nord-est
de la syrie
l'objectif notre objectif c'est
évidemment de faire en sorte que ceux
qui ont commis ces crimes
et il ne s'agissait pas d'une visite de
courtoisie à l'est au cours de ces
années dans cette région
c'est clairement faire un choix notre
objectif c'est que ferran de faire en
sorte que ceux qui ont fait ce choix
soit jugé soit condamné et soient punis
à la hauteur de leurs crimes et leurs
crimes sont immenses mais monsieur le
sénateur lorsque en irak
lorsqu en irak un certain nombre de ces
français qui se sont rendus coupables de
crimes commis en irak ont été arrêtés
détenus jugés et condamnés
nous n'avons rien trouvé à redire la
situation est un peu différente et vous
le savez parfaitement une autre question
l'illustrent dans le nord-est de la
syrie
pourquoi parce que ceux qui sont détenus
aujourd'hui sont détenus par les kurdes
parce que la décision unilatérale des
états unis de se désengager de la syrie
a suscité chez les kurdes des
interrogations considérables et
pourraient susciter et je le dis
évidemment avec beaucoup de prudence car
je suis incapable de la firme est ici
mais pourrait susciter des décisions de
réorganisation de l'effort des forces
d'autres priorités qui pourrait là
encore je le dis avec prudence avoir
pour effet non pas de garder en
détention
ces terroristes mais de les relâcher de
les disperser
et vous voyez bien monsieur le sénateur
qu'il n'est dans l'intérêt de personne
et certainement pas de notre pays de
voir se disperser des ennemis de la
france
ce que je veux dire monsieur le sénateur
c'est que si ces personnes sont expulsés
de syrie
et si elle venait à être en contact avec
les autorités françaises elles seraient
autant d'émoi bien immédiatement arrêté
soumis à la justice
et je l'espère je le crois puni et punis
sévèrement
c'est notre objectif faire en sorte que
ceux qui se sont rendus coupables de
crimes et le simple fait d'avoir été sur
place et souvent déjà constitutifs d'un
crime puisse être condamné
notre intérêt je le redis parce que j'ai
entendu beaucoup de prises de position
sur ce sujet depuis quelques jours
beaucoup étaient empreintes de vraies
inquiétudes
beaucoup étaient empreintes d'une vraie
hauteur de vue certaines étaient
empreintes parfois de très grande
facilité et d'une facilité confondante
je veux dire notre objectif encore une
fois c'est l'intérêt objectif de la
france c'est qu' il n'y ait pas de
dispersion de ces terroristes
nous prendrons donc toutes nos
responsabilités et nous mettons en place
tout ce qui est nécessaire pour faire en
sorte que si ces personnes venaient à
être expulsées elles puissent faire
l'objet de procédures judiciaires
extrêmement sévères de la part de notre
pays monsieur ali jarre
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le premier ministre il faut
dire la vérité aux français
ces prisonniers seront ils échangent et
avant ce retour par les milices contre
des prisonniers détenus par beige
c'est un risque que vous n'avez pas cité
par ailleurs la réponse judiciaire en
faire les revenants majeur vous le savez
est tributaire de la preuve ils
tenteront tout pour minimiser leur rôle
un dossier judiciaire fragile c'est une
condamnation faibles assuré et un retour
dans la société à brève échéance
ce n'est pas acceptable enfin c'est un
problème dont l'europe doit se saisir
car les jihadistes comporte de nouveaux
de nombreux européens dans leurs rangs
la charte de londres et le statut de
rome vous le savez le permettent
nous parlons ici de crimes de guerre de
crimes contre l'humanité et de génocide
je crois que votre volte face n'est que
le marqueur d'une certaine faiblesse de
la politique étrangère au levant ils ne
doivent pas revenir
[Applaudissements]